[موسيقى]
اعلى معدل حراره يومي قبيل العصر فتجتمع
في حراره السطح ما حراره الاجواء واخفض
معدل حراره يومي قبيله الفجر فتجتمع فيه
بروده السطح مع بروده الاجواء فالشمس
اساسا للحراره وغيابها يجلب البروده
فالصيف حار ليش لان النهار طويل والشتاء
بارد ليش لان الليل طويل وعنده وصول الشمس
الى خط الاستواء نزولا تبدا تخزن البروده
وعند وصولها الى مدار السرطان تنفذها على
هيئه صقيع خلال موسمي المربعانيه والشغل
ديسمبر ويناير هبت هبوب الشمالي وبردها
شين ما تدفي النار لو حنا شعرناها ما يطفي
مريوشه العيني ولا عطشنا شربنا منه
انا ياها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فعلاقه الشمس بالارض علاقه تلازوميه فمن
لوازم الحياه وجود الشمس فمنها نستمد
الضوء والدفء والشمس تمسك الارض من
الانفلات الكوني ولهذا جميع شعوب الارض
قدسوها ومن هم العرب والعرب وضعوا للشمس
رمزيات تدل على القوه والانتشار والجمال
يا بنت لولا الشمس ما كان فيه نور واحنا
بدون النور ما نعشق الشمس بنيت لك بالحلم
في داخل القصور كنت احسب ان الحب يا بنت
بالهمس
[موسيقى]